[Musique]
alors c'est votre journée chanceuse
c'est l'émission tam-tam canada vendredi
13 beau soleil sur la capitale
économique du québec en ce moment les
collections là on va saluer sur ces
belles images de radio canada
filmé par radio canada maintenant vous
montrer ces images de radio canada
international en direct de notre studio
c'est le studio 26 juin écoutez vous
savez la tradition vous avez pas l'idée
d' idée du sujet des missions vous avez
eu vent de la présence de notre prochain
éviter connaissez sans doute son nom
vous est peut-être lui dise des choses à
son sujet récemment mais vous ne
connaîtrez pas le sujet des missions je
vous le promets mais pourtant je vais
vous mettre au défi vous allez tenter de
nous faire mentir
je vais vous proposer la vidéo numéro 5
images cinq images pour que vous nous
disiez c'est quoi le sujet cette semaine
de l'émission avec lequel on va devoir
se débattre et débattre d'accord on
regarde son diable puis j'ai peut-être
une surprise dans cette vidéo
parce que ça vous aurait pas le bouquin
une bonne surprise
toujours rien vous cacher des
manifestations le jour 21 souffre assez
d'être acquis qui probablement
manifestent contre je ça a l'air d'être
sa oui tout ça c'était de cet été
[Musique]
alors je vous ajoutez des images parce
que je suis sûr vous n'avez pas
connaître le sujet de la semaine dans
les cours de justice
le premier ministre du québec ne
m'arrête
alors quand vous mettez tous à 21
rachida azdouz et voici le sujet de
l'émission le livre le livre voilà parce
que rachida elle est spécialiste des
relations interculturelles la même façon
de présenter les choses sans faire la
critique de tout le monde ou beaucoup de
gens aient leurs propos elle propose à
tous des arguments pour discuter un peu
plus de ce qui leur apparaît très très
juste dans une société pour qu'on
apprenne à mieux vivre ensemble je pense
façon de plus ne touche pour présenter
cette affaire et je sais qu autour du
projet de loi 21 il y aura des points de
vue divergents ici autour de la table
j'en suis conscient c'est un dessin à la
main dessus j'ai parlé en privé une mort
digne de moi et je on va exposer donc ce
qui ce qui nous traversent ce qui nous
divise et ce qui devrait nous rassembler
aujourd'hui d'accord mais vous étiez
tous sur la bonne pêcheur je dois
l'admettre
d'accord mais grâce à rachida on va
pouvoir avoir une bonne réflexion
dépasser les réflexions populiste qui
vont trop trop trop loin trop rapidement
par un sol humide accord pas de chicane
dans la cabane est bon il faut dire que
c'est pas encore disponible en librairie
chance et on est toujours la primeur
nous sommes là ce sera dispo nous
seulement 18 le 18 septembre n'ont pas
18 octobre 18 septembre aujourd'hui on
est le 13 octobre alors septembre c'est
ce que j'ai dit c'est la seconde vague
souvenir que me revient en tête avec ça
pas de chicane dans la cabane par
rapport à la bonne femme
ouais je sais pas pourquoi ça me revient
c'est une expression très québécoise il
ya aussi l'autre qui était c'est la
classique c'est ça alors je sens que
c'est un lit qui va résonner de par son
style et on l'espère de par son contenu
je vais dire le mot magique et on va
voir ce qui va se produire en studio
action duriez action c'est moi qui
devais faire quelque chose j'ai fait
mettre à la porte d'aix
après il y aura d'autres épices
contre l'émission alors c'est le premier
tour de la grosse boule voir le
règlement sans but la perte par émission
des petites boules mais ça devient des
grosses boules pour certaines et des
boules à perdre pour ce premier jeu on
affiche la question du premier tour de
boules et voici quel pourcentage selon
vous des néo-canadiens donc ceux qui
sont arrivés au canada depuis au moins
depuis dix ans et plus approuvent la
manière de légiférer la marijuana de
joux s'être donc je vous pose cette
question là puisque le dossier des
tolérances d intolérance ça est
reconduit dans la campagne électorale
actuellement campagne électorale
fédérale
et on dit que les néo canadiens qui des
fois pas revêtu rebords des foulards ce
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de juste justin
trudeau et de son message à l'égalité la
justice et le retour du canada sur la
scène internationale et ce qu'ils
approuvent plus que les autres canadiens
c'est le fond de la question
alors que le pourcentage des néo
canadiens approuvent la manière de
légaliser par exemple la marijuana de
justin trudeau est ce que c'est 35% gare
9% ou 58% sur une valeur comme celle là
qu'est ce qu'ils disent dans leur
approbation désapprobation
moi je dirais 58 58 à pro à bouffe ils
sont en accord avec la façon dont justin
trudeau procède dans le dos d'accord
répond avec 35 35 pour ça donc ils
voient ça ils sont moins été plus
conservateurs ou plus réservé à bari ben
moi j'hésite entre 35 et 49 parce que je
me demande est ce qu'on parle des néo
canadiens dans le reste du canada ou au
québec parce qu'on sait qu'au québec
canada
la légalisation était plus populaire que
dans le reste du canada
je vais aller avec 49 pour faire
différent avec laquelle il avait
légalisé la faire jusqu'à maintenant
alors voici la réponse ont fait
apparaître la bonne réponse alors je
pense que marie soit conservé
fantastique les autres vous perdez
vraiment ça vous va je vous présente à
vous présenter notre invité je vous
présente notre vidéo numéro 2 ça va vous
rappeler de bons souvenirs
vous allez me dire et coûteux pour
symbole de plus à quel moment
est-ce qu'on a filmé ces images à tam
tam canada c'était par rapport à c'était
l'an dernier au mois de septembre alors
qu'ils avaient des élections au québec
il a été beaucoup question des
immigrants de leur gros de leur place
puis le partie qui est finalement
remportée le pouvoir voulait limiter
leur nombre
énormément de changer d'idée depuis le
rebond de ces images et vous allez me
dire je vais donner la réponse
quel moment on a filmé ça et là c'est
difficile à dire parce que là c'est une
démission
c'était plus loin que on devait vous
présenter mes façon générale ça vous
rappelle des vieux souvenirs anciens
studios oui mois des élections alors
quelle maman de l'année l'an dernier fin
septembre début octobre de plus vrai
cette année avec une chemise à manches
longues qui proche de la bonne réponse
25 boula les élections parce que j'ai dû
cesser la question pourquoi je suis allé
voter c'était à l'automne c'est en
octobre à septembre
ce 6 septembre 10 octobre ok lui il a 17
octobre puis malzieu 13 novembre
non la presse c'était la galère 19
septembre bonne réponse maryse 5 boules
de plus vous êtes à 505 ouais mais ça se
perd rapidement avec les prochaines
questions alors faut pas trop s'énerver
elle voudrait lancer de rachida azdouz
psychologue et spécialiste des relations
interculturelles était avec nous et la
voici la voilà résidence et un plaisir
de vous inviter pour la troisième fois à
notre émission en un peu plus d'un an et
demi et c'était un plaisir d'être avec
vous bonjour la première fois qu'on vous
invitez c'était lors de la publication
d'un livre je pense c'était votre tout
dernier avant celui de
la cabane est ce que vous souvenez du
titre je me souviens plus mais c'était
aussi très jolie c'est un beau succès il
y avait une copine on va faire si
c'était que le titre de ce livre que
vous aviez écrit à ce moment là environ
un an et demi oui alors c'était de vivre
ensemble n'est pas arras beauchamp alors
là vous publier un nouveau livre
j'imagine que vous avez pris avait fait
le plein d'informations depuis les
derniers mois depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir du nouveau gouvernement qui a su
faire adopter à l'assemblée nationale du
québec
une idée loi qui finalement était dans
les cartons du pain du gouvernement du
parti québécois et a pas eu de grand
débat au québec comme il y en avait
connu il ya 4 ou 5 ans lorsque le parti
québécois avait dit pas écouter les gens
qui sont en autorités qui ont des signes
religieux en société il faudrait
interdire ça cette fois ci s'est passé
pendant comme une lettre à la poste mais
je laisse envisager cinq québécois sur
six sont sont d'accord avec cette loi
qui est unique et ya protestation à en
cours actuellement
devant l'écho fédéral parce que ça
violerait la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés
est ce que votre livre part de ça où
nous donne des éléments de réflexion par
rapport à ce qui se produit en langue
avec oui alors juste rapidement bon
livre parle de trois contreverse l'idée
c'est que le livre commence à l'été 2010
8 et il se termine à l'été 2010 9
donc je fais une espèce de tour de tour
de l'horloge d'une année de l'été à
l'été à travers trois controverse
la controverse autour de la laïcité
l'élan tendue du projet de loi mais
aussi la controverse sur l'appropriation
culturelle qui a aussi marqué toute
l'année avec l'été 2018 cela avait
kanata et une troisième controverse qui
a beaucoup s'y fait couler d'encre cette
année c'est à dire le retour de
l'éducation à la sexualité à l'école et
comment aborder
et quelle place accorder entre autres
aux minorités sexuelles
et à la question lgbt trans la fluidité
sexuelle etc
donc c'est vraiment un livre sur les
trois controverse mais en île à l été
2010 8 et et 2018
alors c'est sa probable parce que vous
pourriez écrire un livre à chaque année
là il se passe tellement de choses mais
la question de de l'enseignement de la
sexualité est effectivement ça traîne
depuis des années c'est depuis 2004 2004
je pense que des gros des bottes sont là
dessus que la chose d' avance pour
beaucoup marie oui je me demandais parce
que l'on parle peut-être d'inclure
l'enseignement de la sexualité dans le
cours d'éthique et culture religieuse
est ce que vous avez eue dans votre
livre un aperçu de ce que ça pourrait
être créé peut-être comme tension ou
peut-être que ce serait bénéfique nous
en fait que c'était cette proposition
est arrivé mon livre était déjà à
l'impression mais dans le livre je
j'aborde la question de comment
l'aborder dans le fond de court et quels
éléments de conques de contenus y mettre
et css d'hazard mais j'ai fait un
parallèle avec éthique et culture
religieuse donc les critiques qui sont
adressées aux cours sur la sexualité
s'appuie beaucoup sur les critiques qui
ont des enfants les gens qui se méfie de
secours utilise beaucoup le cours
d'éthique et culture religieuse pour
justifier leur méfiance
ils disent justement on nous avait dit
ça aussi sur éthique et culture
religieuse et finalement le cours n'a
plus rien à voir avec ce qui a été
annoncé
donc comment vous pouvez nous assurer
qu'il y aura pas les mêmes dérapages et
les mêmes dérives
maintenant quant à l'idée d'inscrire la
sexualité dans le cours d'éthique et
culture religieuse
c'est pas une très bonne heure une très
bonne idée parce que le cours d'éthique
et culture religieuse ne peut pas être
un fourre-tout déjà qu'il ya des
questions sur le fait de mettre les tic
dans culture religieuse parce que
l'éthique
il ya de la philosophie
dedans et il faut pas donner
l'impression que seuls les religions ont
le monopole de l'éthique et ont des
réponses à nos questionnements éthiques
et à nos questions éthiques
donc ajouter la sexualité là dedans
d'abord c'est faire reposer un fardeau
beaucoup trop lourd sur les professeurs
et d'éthique et culture religieuse et et
s'est aussi transformé secours en un
fourre tout quand on sait pas quoi faire
avec un contenu on le met dans éthique
et culture religieuse
marie-claude d'abord j'ai deux remarques
d'abord je n'en reviens pas de votre
coffre bourré c'est écrire un livre
comme au fur et à mesure où les
événements arrivent parce que finalement
c'est un peu ce que vous avez fait c'est
presque un journal personnel ça arrive
vous écrivez sur l'événement vous avez
réussi à concentrer rapidement comment
vous expliquez votre processus par
rapport à ça d'abord en me disant
beaucoup vous remarquerez que je me suis
pas beaucoup beaucoup trop me prononcer
je me suis pas beaucoup prononcés durant
l'année j'ai prononcé des conférences
bien entendu et tout mais j'ai pas
brillé par m'engager pas été surexposés
parce que j'écoute est donc en
l'écoutant au fur et à mesure ça vous
permet de vous construire une analyse
par ailleurs ces sujets là sont les
sujets de l'année
mais dans les fêtes ça fait plusieurs
années qu'on en parle
la laïcité c'est un sujet qui est pas
qui est pas un sujet d'actualité en fait
ça m'a fait ça fait plutôt risque disant
ok bien qu'on en parle
donc il y avait quand même une analyse
qui étaient déjà là donc j'ai ajouté
j'ai ajouté la polémique de l'allée la
même chose pour l'éducation à la
sexualité vous savez que c'est un cours
qui existait déjà avant on la réforme du
curriculum de 1998 qui a disparu et qui
revient à la faveur de deux ans suite à
houdan la foulée du mouvement mis tout
de suite au mouvement btu on a pris
conscience que il fallait apprendre à
des enfants la notion de consentement
mieux connaître leur corps etc
pour l'appropriation culturelle ça c'est
peut-être le sujet le plus particulier
ce qui explique pourquoi tout le premier
chapitre de mon livre qui peut être lent
pour des gens qui ont suivi l'actualité
mais qui pour le commun des mortels qui
n'a pas suivi comprend pas ce qui s'est
passé en juin 2018
il a appris que de spectacle avait été
annulé pour appropriation culturelles et
les gens comprenaient pas d'où ça venait
tout ça il ya des gens qui découvrent mm
ce concept là mais mais je le corps se
refait l'historique des événements ça
fait quand même quelques années que la
table est mise pour une polémique sur
l'appropriation culturelle et mon
objectif était de refaire l'historique
récent vous avez 2 à l'halloween
depuis quelques années à chaque
halloween il y à un incident sur
l'appropriation culturelle ou un début
un déguisement maladroit l'accès des
personnes qui portent des dreadlocks
donc oui oui je réagis à soa des
événements et à la controverse de
l'année mais en même temps je la
raccroche à une réflexion et une analyse
qui est un peu moins récentes tout ce
que j'ajoute c'est des éléments très
très ponctuelle par exemple à chaque
fois qu'il ya un incident je les ajouter
dans mon corps mon dans ma réflexion en
cède un incident durant l'année mais
sinon mon analyse
elle ne s'appuie pas sur uniquement les
éléments récents mais vraiment sur des
événements beaucoup plus anciens
rachida ya quelque chose qu'on voit
venir depuis au moins plus qu'un an
depuis la nomination de james singh
comme leader du nouveau parti
démocratique
c'était il ya deux ans missionnaires
sont bons et on disait à l'époque les
canadiens et liront jamais un premier
ministre qui porte un turban et on sait
que cette polémique elle les temps est
en croissance
il ya eu des problèmes la semaine
dernière ou ne vous prendrez qu'est ce
que ce sujet là on a dit que ça se
passera en acadie ou la portion
française nouveaux produits qui avaient
une réticence je ne peux pas plus qu'une
résistance une résistance
il ya aussi eu des échos à toronto
le frère de jamison a été interpellé par
un populisme
à droite qui fait des actes de
spectaculaires qui sont captés par les
médias reproduit sais c'est présentement
dans la tête de beaucoup de canadiens et
des électeurs la tolérance et
l'intolérance par rapport aux signes
religieux des personnes en autorité
je pense qu'on est en train de ça
revient ça rebondit est ce qu'il ya une
différence par rapport à l'attitude des
canadiens français des québécois et des
canadiens anglais par rapport à ça
est-ce que vous envoyez une entrée
croire que ce soit des anglophones oui
parallèle religieux dans la vie publique
de signes religieux dans la vie publique
écoutez e.on a c'est sûr que tout les
toutes les tous les sondages qui sont
sortis récemment mais beaucoup de son
argent sur le degré d'acceptabilité des
signes religieux visibles dans l'espace
public il ya toujours une petite
différence entre le canada anglais et le
calme et le québec
mais la différence c'est pas énorme elle
n'est pas significative
elle est la mairie pas énorme maintenant
pour ce qui est de jacky singh est ce
que ce qui serait intéressant de voir
c'est est ce que vous savez il ya eu un
raz-de-marée je pensais les élections
donnent corps à l'époque de 2015 et huer
raz-de-marée npd est ce que est ce que
si on revenait en 2015 si on revenait en
2015 et que c'était lui
avec son signe religieux est ce qu'ils
ont vécu un talent tel raz-de-marée
on peut pas le savoir donc aujourd'hui
quelle est la part il faut attribuer au
fait qui porte un turban et quelle est
la part qu'il faut attribuer au fait que
tout simplement ce sont les idées du npd
c'est comme la vague qui est passé
serait prématurée de tout mettre sur le
compte de son signe religieux autre
chose d'important vous savez au début de
l'émission vous montriez des images ou
des gens disaient l'important c'est ce
qui est raciste que j'ai dans la tête et
pas sur la tête et parfois
en voulant contrer les discriminations
et en voulant dénoncer le fait que des
personnes sont intolérants envers un
signe religieux
on se met à pleinement mettre l'accent
sur le site religieux qu'on fait le
contraire de ce qu ont parfois ont
produit l'effet contraire à celui
recherché
on a tellement parlé de ce qu'il a sur
la tête que ben finalement même des gens
qui le soutiennent et que personne que
des ya des gens qui ont peut-être oublié
ce qu'il avait dans la tête
donc parfois le mieux est l'ennemi du
bien eh bien oui oui je me demandais
parce que sam été repéré un peu lorsque
vous parliez de réaction moi j'ai fait
un papier sur une équipe québécoise qui
joue un nouveau brunswick et dont le
lanceur est d'origine sud-américaine et
il s'est fait invectiver par des gens
nouveau brunswick
vous parliez tantôt stéphane du nouveau
brunswick et ya des québécois qui se
sont fait insulter parce qu'ils étaient
français et lui s'est fait insulter
parce qu'il était d'ailleurs alors ce
phénomène leur île et hop on le voit un
peu partout au canada
je pensais avoir bien compris c'est quoi
le phénomène est belle le phénomène de
ne pas accepter une autre culture
oui absolument ça existe partout
absolument je pense que là la différence
peut-être au canada dans le reste du
canada c'est peut-être la présence
beaucoup plus grande dans des
institutions publiques par exemple donc
les gens sont plus habitués à voir avoir
une différence très visible surtout une
différence religieuse mais il faut pas
confondre la tolérance et l'indifférence
c'est pour ça que c'est important d'être
très prudent ce n'est pas parce qu'on
les effectifs pas quelqu'un ou que qu'on
accepte et qu'on va l'inviter dans son
salon et quand on va en faire un ami
il faudrait voir ou bien de canadiens
dans le reste du canada on décèle des
amis intimes ont dans leurs familles des
couples mixtes
c'est tout ça qu'il faut voir on peut
pas se limiter uniquement à des
incidents ou des personnes
tu es intolérante pour dire le onze du
canada est entièrement plus tolérant et
le québec est entièrement intolérant
donc il faut faire il faut effectivement
partout ça existait on peut activer
quelqu'un partout partout dans le canada
et partout dans le monde grâce aux
différents vraiment rachida azdouz
est-ce que la différence de l'un vers
l'autre
est ce que cette différence n'est pas
essentiellement un vecteur de de
craintes pour plusieurs nombre de gens
vont aller vers l'autre par ce qui est
différent mais dans plusieurs tranches
de la société
la différence fait craindre parce qu'on
ne la connaît pas et on a des des porte
voix qui se servent effectivement de
cette différence par spu parce qu'ils
ont un agenda politique
oui absolument je pense que ce que ce
que vous dites vraiment est très
important c'est que quand on veut
comprendre quand on veut comprendre le
phénomène de l'exclusion
la première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
de documenter d'avoir des données et
donner des données quantitatives et ça
on a des statistiques statique
statistique canada documente
régulièrement les incidents haineux et
le non seulement les incidents est nommé
aussi de motifs
est ce que c est ce que c'est de
l'homophobie est ce que c'est du racisme
est ce que est ce que c'est à cause de
la couleur est ce que c'est à cause de
la religion donc et le phénomène de
l'exclusion et du rejet de l'autre
existe et personnes et à la brigade
aussi des gens qui sont rejetés pour
parler tout à l'heure des francophones
quelque part au canada qui peuvent aussi
parfois victimes de rejet
donc il faut le document t il faut où il
faut avoir des données quantitatives et
ensuite il faut le qualifier pourquoi on
rejette l'autre et des fois
effectivement c'est de la peur et ça
m'amène quelque chose de très important
j'essaie de d'étayer dans le livre c
c'est toute la question du racisme et de
la grille antiraciste la grille entre la
grille d'analysé d'une grille d'analysé
antiracistes et la grille des colonials
sort des grilles qui permettent de
comprendre pourquoi l'autre nous rejette
d'accord et l'autre peuvent ou rejetés
parce qu ils nous détestent parce qu'il
a la haine de l'autre parce qu'il est
convaincu que l'autre est un être
inférieur où elle être dangereux la ce a
rejoint le populisme tout menace qu il
va nous envoyer qui va vous envahir qui
va nous enlever notre culture nos
traditions et qui va imposer des siennes
donc ce populisme existe et ça la grille
d'analysé antiracistes et des colonials
permis de comprendre ce phénomène est de
lutter contre ce phénomène
mais la grille antiracistes et donc les
grilles d'analysé antiracistes et des
colonials ne permettent pas de
comprendre et de régler d'autres
phénomènes notamment celui de l'autre
qui le qu'il vous rejette à ce qu'il ait
pas d'accord avec vous parce qu'il n'a
pas la même conception du monde que vous
regardez dans tout ce débat sur la
laïcité
il ya des gens qui ont élu des propos
carrément racistes et extrêmement
dénigrant envers la religion et mais il
ya des personnes qui ont des arguments
tout à fait solide quand on prend
quelqu'un au québec comme dit rocher il
est un intellectuel quand même
respectable et et ils défendent laïcité
sans titi veut pas de signes religieux
chez les fonctionnaires
on peut pas dire que dit rocher a sorti
des arguments à 6
absolument d'accord et la sortie des
arguments qui sont intellectuellement
défendable qu'on peut très bien aussi
ont recontrer et contredire on peut lui
opposer d'autres arguments
mais on peut pas dire que cette personne
qui pourtant a défendu une position où
il veut pas que les fonctionnaires
portent des signes religieux
on peut pas lui reprocher à lui d'être
de la même garde que les racistes de
droite populiste qui se servent de la
différence pour rejeter et dénigré et ça
je pense qu'en ce moment on n'a pas
beaucoup d espace pour ça et on revit
oui c'est comme si toute personne qui
défend des la laïcité
quel que soit le degré de laïcité et
quels que soient les arguments qu'elle
invoque tout de suite on va dire qu'elle
est raciste et vice versa une personne
une personne qui va dire écoutez moi je
ne porte pas de signes religieux mais
j'ai pas de problème avec le fait que
une infirmière qui me soigne en porte ou
une enseignante qui en scène à mon
enfant emporte elle va tout c'est être
identifiée comme une religieuse
intégristes qui se reconstitue l'alizé
l'espace public donc peuvent alors
qu'elle a peut-être des arguments qui
sont tout à fait valable aussi mes
cartons et fument rachida quinton
effectivement quand on rend retire de
l'aspect émotif du dialogue on rentre là
dans un
dans une conversation sans c est sage
sur cette analyse laboratoire du vivre
ensemble c'est ça et c'est la conjointe
mais là je retourne à ce que vous avez
écrit le titre de deux heures de ce
texte que vous avez écrit où vous
utilisez une vieille expression d'ici
pour amener le contemporain d'ici dans
l'espace public est absolument c'est
toujours moi je moi j'ajouterai que
c'est ce que n'ont pas se leurrer c'est
en fait comme qu'est ce que vous
suggérez pour qu'on puisse vraiment
améliorée finalement le dialogue au lieu
de ces difficultés de part et d'autre
raciste intégristes pour que finalement
la rue qu'est ce que vous suggérez comme
dans un premier temps ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai simulé des conversations
entre les deux camps montrent ce qui
était pour le cours d'éducation à la
sexualité les contres pour
l'appropriation culturelle contre un
pour le projet de loi
j'ai pas pcc pas pour le projet de loi
mais c'est beaucoup plus pour une
laïcité qui permet l'affichage de signes
religieux aux fonctionnaires ou non
parce que dans le fond c'était ça
l'enjeu du projet de loi 21 s'était pas
de dire à ce qu'on l'ait pour les signes
religieux dans les centres commerciaux
c'était vraiment dans chez les
fonctionnaires en position d'autorité
donc j'ai circonscrit pour éviter la
pagaille l'amalgamé est ce que se
propose dans un premier temps c'est
d'écouter les arguments des uns et des
autres donc je leur permets jeu permet
quand ils conversent entre eux c'est sûr
qu'ils sont pas très gentils les uns
avec les autres
je ne fais pas semblant de simuler un
débat polian que les deux ils se disent
des choses qui se prêtent des intentions
rouler l'autre ils sont sarcastiques
mais au moins ils sortent leurs
arguments ce qui est pas possible parce
que quand quand il ya eu des débats sur
les trois sujets c'est un débat télévisé
ou à la radio ça dure six minutes 6
minutes et ça inclut la période de
questions et il ya souvent 3,4 parfois
c'est gravité pour un débat de dix
minutes où chacun a la possibilité de
dire de d'intervenir trois fois et l'on
n'a pas le temps de lui répondre dans
son shaka arrive pour exposer son point
de vue il sait qu'il n'a pas le temps de
répondre à l'autre donc il y à passer
son message
donc c'est pas un vrai débat c'est la
position
ça fait cinq minutes là et puis ils ont
presque le temps positive
facile pour eux alors mais c'est pas
grave parce que moi ça permet de
présenter le livre est présenté aussi
mon intention pour que les gens
comprennent aussi c'était pas mon
intention
donc mon intention c'était vraiment ce à
dire
aucune de ces parties là où aucune de
ces aucun de ces camps n'a eu la
possibilité de d'exposer un point de vue
jusqu'au bout de bien ce qu'il a lu de
bien s'expliquer soit il a eu l'occasion
de le faire mais tout seul c'est à dire
dans une chronique dans un journal donc
il a parlé tout seul et les gens qui lui
répondent c'est les gens qui font des
commentaires souvent c'est pas des
commentaires très gentil ok ou c'est des
commentaires très gentil et très
complaisant ok alors là quand il dit il
discute
il ya même des arguments que j'ai dû
inventer en me mettant à la place de
l'eau à dire qu'est ce que j'aurais
répondu si j'étais à sa place
et qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce qu'on peut
raisonnablement répondre à l'autre en
gardant quand même le temps aux arts
plastiques parce que je peux pas faire
semblant que les gens sont polis entre
eux quand ils ne sont pas mais juste
finir une conversation juste jusqu'au
bout et permettre à chacun de sortir ses
arguments mais quand son argument est
choquant et mais l'autre l'arrêt 3,81
raciste août et fascistes ou des
islamistes ou où étaient idiots utiles
et c'est donc un jeu permet à la
conversation d'avoir lieu jusqu'au bout
même quand les gens sont pas toujours
très poli les uns envers les autres
tout ce que j'ai éliminé c'est des
arguments franchement fasciste parce que
ça au canal d rect
j'ai pris vraiment des arguments
contradictoires un peu elle peut
qu'enhardir muscler la paz pas gentil
mais j'ai enlevé les arguments salle
schiste et ensuite ce que je propose
je simule dans un chapitre que j'ai
appelé débattre et comment les mêmes
arguments aurait pu être invoquée il sur
un ton peut-être un peu plus polis et un
peu plus constructif
donc c'est ce que je propose et je
propose quelques quelques repères
quelles sont les conditions minimales
pour permettre
un débat est le débat je n'aime pas le
mot débat serein parce qu'un débat n'a
pas eu lieu sur tout ça respectueux oui
harmonieux voilà constructif et c est
donc quelques quelques conditions qui
doivent être réunies et je répartis eu
des responsabilités la responsabilité
des médias la responsabilité d'aider
j'utilise par exemple le le débat sur
l'appropriation culturelle parce que
c'est là où justement toutes les
conditions n'ont pas été réunies tout le
monde s'est mis à vouloir se montrer
plus fin que l'autre est à dire moi j'ai
compris moi je suis gentil et oui
effectivement la coopération culturelle
c'est horrible c'est assez heureux et
d'autres qui disait au contraire c'est
n'importe quoi c'est de la bêtise donc
sur l'appropriation culturelle
les dirigeants les responsables surtout
les responsables d'organismes culturels
certains d'entre eux ont été
irresponsables parce qu'ils ont pris des
décisions très rapidement
mais le débat sur l'appropriation
culturelle n'est pas fini ils avaient
qu'à la table en fait que de lancer il
ya plein de choses qui sont pas claires
sur par exemple la validation des
oeuvres et qu'est ce qu'on entend par
valider une oeuvre qu'ils allaient leed
qui a l'autorité morale et la légitimité
parce que pour moi tomber dans
l'ascenseur là non plus non à la tutelle
la tutelle donc alors quand on quand on
voit des décisions qui sont prises et
des conditions qui sont imposées à des
artistes et des créateurs
il faut se demander est ce qu a eu
consensus et ce qui est véritablement
départ donc dans le chapitre sur
l'appropriation culturelle quand je
simule le débat le débat est très musclé
très chaud pas toujours tripoli
mais je le fais exprès d'une part parce
que c'est comme ça que ça se passe dans
la vie et d'autre part c'est pour dire
regardez c'est pas fini là il ya des
arguments là dedans quand vous enlevez
la colère et le sarcasme et quand vous
éliminer tout ça et que vous regardez
bien les arguments
il ya des arguments qui sont vains
des deux côtés les tenants de
l'appropriation culturelle et ceux qui
sont contre alors avant de prendre des
décisions importantes sur les
subventions
il faut peut-être il faut peut-être
s'assurer qu'on a bien regardé on a bien
analysé et qu'on a balayé les angles
morts c'est très bien que ça l'a écouté
c'est toujours un plaisir de lire vos
livres parce qu'ils sont d'une
simplicité c'est clair puis les trouve
que les jeux d des arguments est
toujours bien présente et et savent
choque pas ça réveille en fait c'est ce
que je trouve ça vraiment très agréable
de vous lire merci beaucoup rachida
rappelle que votre livre pas de chicane
dans la cabane seulement disponible le
18 et le lancement le 18 à la librairie
gallimard très bien fantastique merci
beaucoup rachida psychologue à
l'université du québec à montréal
alors écoutez je vais le dire une fois
encore une fois action c'est le jeu des
grosses boules
on rappelle que maryse à 105 bull et que
les autres ont 80 bull 30 bout la berd à
perdre force au deuxième je vois si on a
parlé un peu de populisme dépendant pas
des fascistes mais parlons des
populistes très simples comme question
on en parle de tous les jours des
populistes en des exemples remarquables
dans le monde
alors voici quelle est l'origine du mot
populisme à on présente la question à
l'antenne c'est un choix de réponses un
mot qui vient du latin et de l'époque du
scénario mais on 1er siècle
est ce que le mot populiste est un mot
populisme qui vient du grec de la ville
d'athènes au cinquième siècle
ou est ce que c'est c'est un mot qui
vient de la russie moderne au 20e siècle
alors on va parler avec notre rue bruce
evolution un spécialiste de la langue
spqr
à l'époque senatus populusque we re mind
essai de la romantique
ces deux-là guen rome antique à bord
c'est du latin de les poches passé terre
romantique autre affaire du passé la
remonte choqué oui moi je dirais j'irai
aussi avec gréement parce que je pense à
l'expression vox populi nombril et voilà
ton mec gir avec pas ouais mais
l'origine on s'entend que ça vient du
mot population populaire même la racine
ou luis paulo
ok mais quelqu'un qui a utilisé
populisme en termes de notions comme ça
de choisir c'est donc qui a répondu à
deux oiseaux là bas d'accord perdue au
fil des saisons la concurence ça
signifie peuple ou c'est un lapin oui
c'est du latin
bah oui c'est sur wii c'est la première
fois c'est apparu sous la plume d'un
écrivain grégoire alechinsky qui est un
russe qui a été obligé de s'exiler à
paris durant la sphère de la grande
révolution 1912 pour la première fois il
a écrit populisme d'ailleurs aimait
beaucoup ce qui situe le populisme on
n'a pensé qu'à l'origine du mot est bel
et bien évoque ce contenu
j'avais les boules ça me dérange pas
dans la voiture à 5 alors je tombais
combien peuvent dans la garonne de 30
mois j'ai cinq ans vous avez 50 et vous
vous avez 4
[Musique]
je savais que toujours à l'émission de
tam-tam canada on vous présente à la fin
de phase iib j'ai de la semaine
ben c'est à dire qu'en plus de pouvoir
le regarder ou l'écouter c'est l'option
de poursuivre la lecture voilà nous on a
rien on peut pas tout lire on peut
seulement dire des choses alors si vous
voulez lire et écouter des entrevues de
radio canada international sur la
question de la bonne entente
interculturel est alors urgent et je
pense que c'est la vidéo attend dé voir
des vidéos numéro 39b 68 locales dans la
tour de radio-canada
on est au niveau b ouais bah c'est la
prochaine vidéo voici c'est bien
celle-là la prochaine qui étaient au
menu
cela là c'est sous la selle ou l'a8 l'a9
là il ya quelqu'un à la régie quittera
garde avec des points d'interrogation
dans les yeux non ce qui l'a bien
remarqué que celle là et bien on peut là
on peut l'écouter non allez-y on peut
tout est passé dans cette émission s'est
fait par radio canada récemment depuis
2015 et réussiront deuxième année on
éducation préscolaire et enseignement
privé fatma et la vie étudiante à
l'université de montréal en enseignement
primaire et préscolaire
je suis là depuis 2015 et je suis
algérienne
inès boutiche originaire d'algérie je
suis arrivé ici au québec en 2016 je
suis en deuxième année
éducation préscolaire et enseignement
primaire elle enseignait déjà dans leur
pays d'origine pour travailler ici elles
ont dû reprendre leurs études
un choix réfléchi pour améliorer leur
sort mais le projet de loi 21 sur la
laïcité est venu jeter un pavé dans la
mare
comment vous prévoyez votre avenir 6,7
ce projet de loi devient la loi nous
l'enseignement c'est une passion que
nous c'est une vocation donc c'était un
choix on a investi du temps d'investir
de l'argent
donc c'est vraiment difficile pour nous
on voit pas notre avenir qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire on sait pas ce qui va se
passer par la suite est ce que je peux
faire mon stage est ce que je peux
enseigner dans une école club vraiment
délicat moi j'étais sélectionnée comme
travailleuse qualifiés ils m'ont
expliqué que je peux travailler ici au
québec y aura aucun problème par rapport
aux signes religieux
alors voilà ce qu'ils y aillent tous
grand père dans la loi 21 maintenant il
avait été alors si vous aviez déjà vous
partiez déjà un foulard à l'école
estienne enseignante la loi j'aime voilà
une job ça ne s'appliquera pas vous mais
les nouvelles enseignantes qui se
joignent aux commissions scolaires
battant leur car elles pourront plus
porter le hidjab
ce qu'ils veulent ce qui crée finalement
deux catégories d'enseignants taux
d'enseignants
c'est une histoire qui pourrait se
retrouver évidemment en cours
éventuellement les droits de personnes
ne sont divisés je pense qu'ils ont
utilisé la clause dérogatoire ce qui
veut dire qu'à part les cinq prochaines
années techniquement ça va rester comme
ça qu'est ce qui arrive après 5,1 à
balla seck qui sera au pouvoir sont
exactement cette question qui a retenti
ce qu'on m'en parler québécois
c'est un rebond dû faire les élections
la campagne électorale ces derniers
jours a demandé ou de surenchère
est-ce que vous au niveau fédéral vous
entendez contester cette loi québécoise
qui selon certains violerait la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés et les
huits réponses différentes à part des
chefs de la police politique
je vais pas réécrire cette histoire
c'est la semaine prochaine c'est sûr
vidéo une roue vite je voulais promis un
peu plus tôt ce sont les articles qui
accompagne cette émission
cette semaine sur la page de tentantes
je pense qu'on va retrouver un reportage
qui fait d'abord par didier aux tirs ou
d'honneur pour les opposants au projet
de loi 21
je vous rappelle que c'est maintenant de
la loi 21 la deuxièmee thème c'est de
raymond vous reconnaissez de la charte
des valeurs du pq à la loi sur la
laïcité de la cac
est ce une répétition du même film et
puis ensuite vous avez les immigrants
francophones dans la baisse au québec
expulsion des immigrants le débat
s'incruste dans les élections
québécoises c'était il ya un an pour
appeler un peu de contexte
et puis aussi je pense et ses 106
articles en tout on termine par la
diminution des migrations va-t-elle
aggravé la pénurie de travailleurs si on
avait une wii déjà une pénurie de
travailleurs parce qu'en ce moment le
québec est le plus de bois tout chômage
au pays
ça ne s'était jamais vu depuis des
années donc on est en manque
on a besoin de chiens qui vient de
s'installer avis donc aux intéressés à
ce qu'ils nous écouterait dans le monde
entier il est possible de postuler au
ministère québécois puis au ministère
fédéral canadien ou si vous faites là
l'immigration est une responsabilité
différente d'accord que son se trouvent
au québec où l'intérêt du canada
c'est ce qu'on appelle le certificat de
sélection du québec
bravo merci beaucoup écouté on n'a pas
terminé tout à fait il nous reste il ya
bien sûr image de la semaine mais il
reste action troisième fois troisième et
dernière fois
dernière question voilà je voulais boyer
très bien cette semaine personne
il ya juste vraiment qui va qui prolonge
et on trouvait à séoul
non non non mon général c'est le
champion alors 50 boules à perdre
vraiment et puis tous les autres mois ci
question numéro 3 qu'elle était en 2016
le taux de participation des néo
canadiens aux élections fédérales à
l'avait cherché longtemps salah ben oui
c'est pas facile à trouver j'ai trouvé
des réponses
est-ce que c'était à 7% plus élevé que
le taux de participation des canadiens
de souche
est-ce que cet ep c'est pour cent moins
élevé que le taux de participation des
canadiens de souche ou est ce que le
taux de participation des néo canadiens
aux élections est exactement le même que
les autres canadiens
moi j'irai avec à 7% plus élevé
à 7 % + wii mon dieu 7 % moins élevés
non il ya division dans la cabane alors
écoutez vous avez bien vous entendre la
bonne réponse c'est vous je l'avais vu
parce qu'en général lorsque les gens
obtiennent leur citoyenneté et qu'ils
votent dans les cinq années après avoir
obtenu leur citoyenneté
ils sont fiers d'être au pays et ils
veulent se prononcer dans le débat
public en battant il ya d'autres dans
d'autres nations des fois ils votent
moins que la population souffre parce
qu'ils craignent d'être de s'exposer aux
récriminations des voisins ils veulent
pas mais là aucun abri semble qu'ils
prennent part davantage et on signalait
de la première question aussi ils votent
davantage présentement pour le parti
libéral du canada sont plus enclins à
voter pour avoir avoir de meilleurs de
meilleur d'un meilleur oeil voilà pas du
meilleur oreilles
la performance du président actuel du
premier ministre actuel premier ministre
vous avez gardé comme une boule il reste
80 oui elle est à 80 mais là vous avez
augmenté moi j'étais à 60,90 jamais
cette émission sur vous aujourd'hui cinq
poules vous êtes à 75 80 on est prêt
pour la devinette pour la semaine
d'accord
quelle est l'image la semaine je ne peux
répondre que par oui ou par non à passer
notre fameuse vedette du tennis
ça aurait été un bon choix quel est son
nom barris ce bien que andré ce qu elle
est maintenant cinquième joueuse et elle
et son monde et qui l a battu serena
williams chose c'était dimanche à dernis
que c'est nord américain est-ce que
c'est nord américain oui c'est north
america exclusivement exclusivement
numérique est américain une catastrophe
naturelle une passe et elle dort bien de
rien on sait rien c'était le rappelez
vous le savez peut-être pas la démission
la semaine dernière à l'image de ce
mineur c'est être relié à dos rien donc
là on a passé deux côtés même s'est
passé au dessus de nouvelle écosse en
fin de semaine
c'est pas l'image la semaine c'est ce
que ces canadiens citerai canal est ce
que c'est le doigt dans l'ouest canadien
non c'est pas dans l'ouest canadien dans
l'est dans l'est c'est pas dans les
méridiens québec qui non monsieur permet
c'est en ontario en ontario ouais c'est
ça à l'université francophone on va
présenter ça tout de suite ce film il
démissionna de perdre de sa tête
voici le voir camion a eu via des
français sont partis
la camion s'est mis à voler puis il a
était terry subitement sur une maison le
policier c'est la première fois qu'on
voit ça c'est la première fois au monde
alors elle sert et brescia écrire lire
pas de camion avec abane n'y a pas eu de
blessés le propriétaire stationnement il
y avait deux personnes en camion pour
les séries voilà c'est tout pour cette
semaine
à voir
[Musique]